- Kelly!
- I'm good.
- It's a new year.
(audience cheering)
It's a new year.
I was watching your rehearsal.
I was getting ready.
I was watching the rehearsal
and I was just like,
oh my god, the amount of time...
First of all, doing it once,
I would die of cardiac arrest.
And then I was like,
y'all do it over and over
and over again.
It's so incredible.
I cannot wait for y'all
to see this performance
he's got for us today.
But last time you were
here, you guest hosted.
- I did, thank you for that.
It was a lot of fun.
- Thank you for that.
It's like COVID times you can't help...
It's like you get it and you're like,
well, can't show up.
- I'm happy to be here.
I live close by so I'm
here whenever you need me.
I got you.
- Oh, my god.
It was so nice.
And you did such a great job.
- Thank you.
It's always hard going to something
and you're like I guess I'll just
work with this team and do this show.
- Which by the way,
your team, this team...
I love this show so much.
- I love my team.
Everybody, the camera
operators, the producers,
everybody here's so kind and so beautiful.
Thank you guys.
- And they're top notch
like, in their field.
They're all like A-level.
It's amazing.
So, how is 2023 going?
Do you make resolutions?
We're like a month and a half in,
have you broken them yet?
- I mean, you know, we do
vision boards and stuff.
Before the new year.
I'm gonna be honest with
you, I didn't finish mine.
- Oh, that's not promising.
- Well, my beautiful fiance did.
She, like, has it all there, ready to go.
- If you don't even
finish your vision board
your resolution is like, in the beginning.
I don't think you're gonna maintain it.
- Either that or I
nailed it already, right?
- You're consistent.
You're consistent.
Oh, my god.
Hayley is in our audience, as well.
Everybody, say hi to Hayley.
(audience cheering)
- It's nice to see you.
You look beautiful.
I was telling you before the show started,
I was like the dress is beautiful.
So does he keep to his resolutions?
- He usually does, but like
he said, he didn't finish his.
- Well, y'all are like trained.
You're like so disciplined in life.
So I guess we all figure you're, like,
you always nail the task you set forth,
like to conquer.
- Honestly, he's been already
really busy this year,
so he's had his brain preoccupied.
So I think we'll get there.
We'll definitely make 'em still.
- Well, one thing on the
resolution is getting married.
- [Kelly] I was gonna say.
Yes.
(audience cheering)
I love that, like, that's
already a huge thing,
getting married, and like planning that.
If you're doing a big wedding
and you're not eloping, that's huge.
But you're also doing a 50-city tour.
- Yes.
- Do you like to set
yourself up for failure?
What?
Are you gonna be medicated
throughout this process?
That's a lot.
- Medicated with dance.
No, I'm so excited.
I'm so excited to go on tour.
It's the first time I've
gone on tour in four years.
- [Kelly] Really?
Yes.
And so this show is gonna be
unlike anything done before.
But also what's really special is
I've never toured with Hayley
since we've been together.
- [Kelly] Didn't y'all meet on tour?
- We did, we met on tour.
- Who hit on who?
Who like opened the door?
- Oh, whoa.
- [Kelly] Who opened the door?
- I think we both opened the door,
simultaneously maybe.
- You just did simultaneously.
- I did that, I did.
I was just wondering, like, I don't know.
I was wondering who made the first move?
I don't know.
- It was fully him.
He's like, I'm gonna
make a story about this.
But I'm like, no, it was definitely him.
- I would say there was a moment
where we were actually on stage dancing.
We're doing a run with the dance of love,
and it was the last show
and the the dancers from
the side of the stage
were all like, "Kiss!"
"Kiss!"
So our first kiss-
- Like a total junior high moment.
I love it.
- It really was.
Our first kiss was actually on stage.
- That's sexy.
- I know.
- I'd watch that movie.
Two dancers falling in love.
Oh, that's nice.
- [Hayley] It was special.
- So y'all are doing a lot,
you're doing the 50 city tour.
You're planning the wedding.
I heard you recently,
You were just in a car accident, right?
- We are doing a lot.
Yeah.
- You were just in a car accident,
like are you okay?
- It was very, very scary and-
- [Kelly] A lot going on in your world.
- It was a wild time.
And unfortunately Hayley
got super injured,
you know, a head injury.
But I say that she's like Wolverine
She heals so fast.
It's unbelievable.
- You're like healthy.
That's what happens.
That's your gift.
- I was also a really good patient.
I was really on top of
taking care of myself.
Like icing constantly.
So I did all the right things.
I'm so grateful to be
okay, that we're okay.
- Were y'all sliding, right?
Is that what I heard?
It was like in snow?
- An icy hill.
- Ice, yeah.
- It was very scary.
And I've said the love from
everybody that reached out,
thank you so much.
You have been so kind.
But also it makes you just
think about just life.
You know?
And just how precious that it is, really.
- And how can be taken so quickly
- So fast.
And so honestly all these experiences
that we share together,
and going out on the road,
and sharing them with
people in their cities.
Like I said, I haven't
been there in four years.
We just cannot wait for this year.
And then getting married.
So many beautiful things.
It's great.
- We talked about your upcoming tour.
What's the inspiration behind the show?
- You know, so much has happened
since I've gone back out
and this is gonna be a brand new show.
I had the Vegas residency,
which was successful and fantastic.
- Kind of cool. You're in one place.
- Yeah, but there's something
about going into a city
just for one night only.
And there's so much I've been collecting
over the past four years,
of music and styles and
costumes and just ideas
and I mean, you're a musician, right?
Meaning like your voice
is your instrument.
- Yeah.
- Being a dancer,
our bodies are an instrument
and so it's like this dance
symphony I want to create
or like a symphony of dance.
- I know, but that's cool
because what I love
about what you get to do
and what I just force my fans to enjoy is
I like different genres of music.
So I like doing all different genres.
It's exciting and I think that's cool
that you get to implement that.
- Yeah, all different
genres of dance and music
and also having live music, you know?
Having that like live brass section
and the live drums just with
the way that the beat hits.
- That energy is so undeniable.
- And of course, the
costumes and the dancing,
the energy.
If anybody's ever been to one of my shows,
we bring the energy for sure.
- I actually didn't know
that you're also a musician.
I didn't know that you played piano.
- I dabble a little bit.
Before I danced actually, I played drums.
I was in the Ballas Hough Band
and that's me with my shirt off.
Yep, there it is.
- If my body look like that,
I'd be naked all the time.
Jeez, celebrate it.
- No, I dabble.
- Gravity will take hold
at some point, Derek.
Celebrate it.
- I'm not gonna lie, there's
been a few times this year
where I'm like, "Wait if I
just, just a little bit."
- Don't, you look beautiful.
You're hot.
You're great.
- But no, obviously music
is the beginning for me,
for everything, you know?
When we dance, the song inspires us.
The instruments, you know.
The orchestra, the strings and the pianos
and the brass and the
winds and the percussion-
- Love the strings.
- Me too.
I love it.
I love a good cello.
- Oh, my god.
My favorite thing is a piano and a cello.
It's magic
And it's so sad.
And it says something about me,
but I just really love the sadness of it.
- It just feels so good.
Or passionate
- And it's just the low end of it.
- It hits you right here.
- I don't tango, but if I were to tango,
I would picture that I look like y'all.
In my brain movie.
It would look different.
I love that though.
That's so cool.
Just the musician side of you,
that's a whole other level
that you can bring forth.
Like in the art of all of it.
- That's my hope is to really integrate
the music and the dance, you know?
To create that symphony of dance, really.
And implementing that too,
you know, like playing
instruments on stage
and then going into a dance
and then having the cello player
and dancing tango around
them or something.
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
- That's so sexy.
Okay.
Do you have any rituals before your-
- That was my sexy leg by the way.
(audience cheering)
- So brash.
So wait, do y'all have any
rituals that you do before?
- You know, just blasting
music, getting excited
but also ice baths after the show.
Without a doubt.
- [Kelly] I wanna try this.
- [Derek] Let's do it.
- Because people say...
- Let's go.
- ...it's really healthy.
So I have these baths set up for us.
Wouldn't that be amazing?
No, I do wanna do it
because I just watched this
whole thing on accident
about it.
And I was like, that's interesting.
And I don't have to work
out, you just sit in it.
I'm really into that.
But it's really healthy for you.
- Yeah, it's really great.
Obviously your inflammation, just recovery
but also it's just good for stress.
- Circulation.
All the things.
All those things.
But that's definitely a big ritual.
Listening to music, getting pumped up.
And I do have like an incantation.
I say something right
before I go on stage.
I wanna share it with you guys.
- I know that's your own to have,
but is it like a superstitious thing?
Because I have something similar.
- It's not so much superstitious,
it's more of just like something
where I demand something for myself.
I'm not like, "I hope
it goes well tonight."
It's like a (thumps chest).
This is something like
I'm going out there,
I'm gonna serve this audience.
I'm gonna give them
everything I absolutely have.
Every night.
So there's no question
that I'm gonna put on
the best show possible
every single night.
There's no question.
- I love how different we are.
We're gonna have to bleep this
but I literally just say to my band,
"Hope we don't (bleep) up."
That's literally what I say.
Hayley, have you ever given him advice
like doing shows and
putting shows together?
'Cause it's kind of interesting, like,
I guess it would be like me
being with a musician, right?
You have input, like you
know what you're both doing
and you're both passionate and creative.
Do you ever like, brainstorm together?
- Yeah, definitely.
I would say I'm more of a
soundboard for him though
because he has so many thoughts
that are going through his head.
Oh, my gosh.
He's the biggest visionary ever.
And I feel like I'm very grounding,
so I like organize all of his thoughts,
so I'm more logistical.
Whereas he's creative
- Hey babe, what about this?
And then we're over here.
What about that?
- And I'm like, hold on.
Okay, how does that even work?
Let's bring this down.
- You found a partner.
That's amazing.
- We make a good team.
We really do.
- That's incredible.
And you can be honest with each other too.
That's the best part.
When you're in a relationship,
you'll be like, that looks stupid.
Don't do that.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a real friend.
You have a booger, like, you know.
So you mentioned that you got
engaged already last year.
So how is the wedding planning going?
Is it fun or do you wanna run?
- Do I wanna run?
No, um-
- I started planning a wedding
and it was so overwhelming
and it became about other
people that I stopped
and I was like, this is too much.
My life is already giving to everybody.
This should be for me.
- When you said that, she looked at me
and she goes like that.
- It does, it becomes for other people.
And it's like, wait, wait, wait.
This should be for us.
But enjoy it though.
Big weddings are fun.
- No, it's exciting.
We're just trying to find the right venue,
but we already have the
entertainment booked
and I've said this a thousand times-
- I love your entertainment.
How did you get Michael Bublé performing?
- [Derek] That's right.
- Michael Bublé is performing.
That's amazing.
- He's gonna be performing
"Baby Shark" at our wedding.
(Kelly laughs)
No, we've just become really close friends
past five years and this
past year even closer.
You know, he's just the best guy.
- First of all, people don't
know if you don't see a show,
if you go to a show you do.
He is one of the funniest people.
- He's a standup comic.
- He's a standup comic that
just sings extremely well.
- He also sings.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's just a side note.
- It's funny, so I actually
did this project with him.
I directed a few videos for him
and we just worked together and you know,
he's like, "What do I owe you?"
And I was like, "Nothing,
nothing, nothing."
He was, "Well, please let
me do something for you."
And I was like, "Sing at our wedding."
And he was like, "Done."
And we shook on it, done.
And I was like, oh, he
probably just said that.
And then later, we saw him and he goes,
"All right so when are
we all getting married?"
Like, when does it happen?
I was like, "So you are?"
He's like, "Of course I said I was."
I was like, "Okay, great."
- A lot of people say things
and don't follow through.
- That's incredible.
- It's a major romance.
- Oh, my god.
- I might marry him.
I might marry him.
- [Kelly] Are you willing to accept-
- See ya later.
- Alright, well we have to
stop for another quick break
but keep an eye out for dates and tickets
to Derek's tour coming this fall.